hello everybody my name is oh boy
Oh fine eight teddy bears hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to slender Elementary oh my this
is different
holy crap no no sat at Eddie bear oh I
like this less already that is not a
teddy bear that isn't no harm that's a
frickin arm oh my god
okay oh that's a teddy bear
that's impaled ah I don't like this at
all
holy crap what is that oh okay I've been
saying that this guy has made it
definite improvement to the slender game
and holy crap and I think my flashlight
broke you can't hide pick up sticks
seven eight oh yeah okay so it's a run
okay I got two yeah I'm on a roll I'm
doing great but anyway this is oh man
it's like ten times worse holy crap why
is it speared through the mouth Oh
Slendy no nose 1900
no not ready for it oh I'm not ready for
it anyway yeah um I like this this guy's
gonna keep doing new stuff like this I'm
definitely definitely gonna keep playing
Wow what dude that is not a teddy bear
help please help me oh my holy crap and
it seems like I'm like I'm sure I'm like
really short I think I'm a kid
I mean this looks at a dead end
do you need any oh maybe that's why
there was a big X on the wall don't go
down this way you freaking dumb but
whatever
oh it says that ahead oh that's the
guy's head that was his arm before look
it's his head why is that it in
elementary school
oh I don't like that door okay I found
four already I'm either this place is
smaller or I will find you please don't
I'd like to be left alone if that's okay
with you
yeah I'm definitely a little kid
Oh what's up aah oh no aah not gonna
happen
get away get away get away get away I've
already been around here and this is
like double extra easy to get turned
around in because like I mean I don't
even know where the hell I am everything
looks the same but aah aah what is this
what it what is you and is that like the
remnants of the other people that were
in here
that's Slendy god aha he's guarding it
come on it but Sunday please oh thank
you please is the magic word the
heartbeats getting quicker and more
irregular holy [ __ ] oh there is no
escape okay that's nice to know I think
I'll just go this way and try and escape
fruitlessly where's that what is that is
that an outside that is oh I get it one
big circle ah what ah
ah
no-no-no
oh no oh no oh no open open live in
middle house left right
I'd say hey think I gotta get outside so
now
oh here we go here we go oh my god
that's a feature that's a new feature
that I both like and definitely do not
like oh my god I'm so close to the end I
got six I got six seven
oh my god my brain my heart MOT spleen
ah okay
holy crap oh my god oh you're a
diabolical genius creator of this game
oh man oh okay was try it again
oh man the new mechanics on salinity
like the in sanatorium the first one
that he released
yeah the mechanics of slender were kind
of the Slenderman kind of buggy but
maybe I liked it that way
cuz this way seems horrifying
I should have known I was in for a giant
piece of hell just by this song that's
much creepier than when deadspace tried
to do it no doubt
on date Teddybears I'm gonna go outside
first and get that one that way when I'm
inside I can just run a circle around
the whole intimate elementary I really
got close I feel I think there might
let's see okay that one's not there
anymore someone on the other side either
way looking behind me is bad so I'm just
gonna try that I'm gonna try to run this
whole circuit without ever looking
behind me unless I'm you know trying to
find where I'm going but okay there's
the first teddy bear that was number
seven that I got oh hey grabbed I'm just
gonna go clockwise alright let's do this
let's do this okay
right that's what happened the whole sky
exploded alright
but everything brightened up but that
didn't help at all anything it didn't
help anything okay I'll go clockwise and
then I will win that's the first one the
second one hello mister head uh uh
killings great is that what that sign
said that's a weird children's poem okay
that is the dead end I do not go in
there okay just doing okay I can run
from him if I need to that's the way in
for the other way there's a teddy bear
around here I remember if it's in the
same place oh boy
there was what I know there was on there
oh there it is there this is the one
okay doing okay I just keep going on I
don't like this each one gets so much
worse so much worse than the last
okay I got four doing good just keep
going don't look behind me don't look
behind it it's taken me four games to
remember to learn that I should not look
behind me okay let's go in here
ah number five doing great on pace to
win it is the arm I remember coming in
here I just got to keep going keep going
man keep going keep going just keep
going just keep going I haven't even
seen mr. Slendy don't look behind me I
like depth - I'm not gonna he's right
behind me isn't hall
it's in there why so many checker go
back damn it
oh ok ok ok still ok still ok what was
that damn it
new
haha number six oh my god I didn't even
see him and I was in that music I don't
even know what that is
I think that's like he's chasing your
music or something
oh six of eight I only need two more
animals there's a seventh and then the
eight should be just around the corner
Oh give me please oh I'm so close let me
win
shut up
shut up run
but please be here somewhere teddy bear
ah right back the address [ __ ] you I
can't [ __ ] effort here here it's here
this is it
[ __ ] run run this is it
I know is it this is it this is that
that let's who's on the other side no
this is it this is that do nothing don't
kill me
ah
aha
I had it oh oh I had it I was so close I
had it it was in my hands oh I was right
there that's why I started right oh okay
I gotta try it again
you know it's just a point of pride I I
have to had it I don't know what
happened though I was I was I thought I
was right there the beginning I Oh like
I'll try it one more time I gotta I'm
gonna do this guy's I'm gonna get this
I'm gonna get this
no bling it on Slendy bling it on I got
this get the one in the courtyard first
I'm gonna remember where I am for the
entrance this was oh no this is the
other side I was on the wrong side crap
oh that's right because when I started
my circuit I was on the other side I'm
an idiot I should get the teddy bear
they seem to be in the same place get
the teddy bear come back through this
way and then start my circuit that way
when I'm done I'll wind up at the
entrance I would just I I miss my route
okay I got this I got a plan I move
forward with it am I good okay you
believe in me right you believe in me
you believe in me I believe in me let me
go Teddy okay first one no big deal I
didn't take my time getting back to
where I was then I just run the circuit
and I'm good this place isn't even that
big it's just very cramped but that
happens that happens I almost forgot
about that all right I got this I got
this guy's oh man this is like the most
tense
Slenderman game ever just because of
that freaking chase music okay just go
clockwise same as always and make it fun
to get it I am going to get this jet if
there was one in here another was no
there was not Frank oh yeah this I
remember it now this is where I popped
in there before and I was like oh
there's not one in ER I was like a big
douche and oh god I wish I had a burden
pepper memory nope
this is wrong too okay but it's okay
these are the only wrong spots
everything else is just like boom boom
boom instantaneous
the teddy bears yep here it is so now
once I get the second one in they start
getting real that's when I go sounds
like good morning high heels just saying
all right number three then I don't know
if there's was one in here wait no yeah
but I should go through there get this
one and go through there all right I
think those that was my number eight
that I got just now before is that that
guy okay don't look back never look back
never look back I know where the other
ones are now I should be good frickin
heartbeat it's just going to destroy me
for hey look it's me hey it's me hey
okay don't look what done wait a minute
there's no way so with it I already got
that one
maybe maybe they do switch places but
there just aren't that many places to
switch them with oh crap I'm so fond all
right I'm not going to deviate from the
plan I'm just going to go in the circuit
again I must have gotten it before
something no no just keep going I was
cool that I was up there I donated this
guy because he's great
and I just thought that you did a great
job and if I'm gonna play his maps on
YouTube I might as well give back that's
a dead end
don't go in there it's just death okay
got the heartbeat I swear okay I know
there's some in this immediate area I
know this not in there but in here got
it
okay red six already haven't even heard
or seen from them don't look back just
keep going this is number seven don't
corner in me here man
okay
number right this is it this is it this
is the winner I'm going to win all run
faster than that you little girl
this is that
kuna yes
I didn't even sim I didn't even say
Slenderman yes yes oh I did yeah yes yes
oh I don't know if you bet if all of you
have watched my other Slenderman plays
but I yes I've never beat it so yes hmm
now let me read this poem in my amazing
reading voice dare grodman oh should I
travel through the woods which are not
wishing I would for above me lurks
within the trees no one could hear my
deathly screams the palest man the black
suit beggar than the tallest brute six
black arms will grab you up or stock you
till you just give up a top hat bears
upon his head makes your soul fill up
with dread he takes you when you least
expect boil you up and eat your neck you
leave your body not to eat but staple
your corpse on a tree fear the man the
Slender Man for he can do what no one
can buy Rustin a Mirani how I did it I I
did it yes oh man that was incredible
everything he did to change it was
amazing you sir are a genius a ruddy
genius thank you so much for making
these maps
I mean Oh Dell is amazing oh god I
haven't I hadn't felt an adrenalin rush
like that when that when I first saw him
and that chase music started that is the
perfect addition and get getting the
idea that he's actually chasing you
because it's never felt like he's ever
you know chase you before and you needed
to get away from him to always just felt
like boom he's there and he got you this
was a marked improvement and if you can
top this in the next one I will play and
i will donate more i'll give you
whatever you need because you are a
great map maker a great game maker every
out there listening in my audience
should go to the website linked in the
description below and just chip in a
little bit to try to get the next the
next project ruling he's like these are
incredible as you can see so and go play
them yourself like if if you can handle
it if you can handle it I don't know if
you can but anyway go play yourself
support the developers for free indie
games like this like this is what gaming
is all about so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next part bye bye